.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich habe schon eine Wut auf die ALS.
Sie hat mir meinen Mann genommen.
Ich bin in der Rolle der Ehefrau
emotional an die Person gebunden.
Vielleicht halte ich das
irgendwann nicht mehr aus.
Die Geschichte beginnt 2013.
Dennis und Daniela
werden ein Liebespaar.
Sechs Monate später
diagnostiziert man bei Dennis
die unheilbare Nervenkrankheit ALS,
mit einer Lebenserwartung
von drei bis fünf Jahren.
Daniela entscheidet sich,
an seiner Seite zu bleiben.
Ein Jahr später, 2015,
kommt Melissa zur Welt.
Während die Tochter
an Lebenskraft gewinnt,
baut der Vater ab.
Doch die Familie kämpft
für ein selbstbestimmtes Leben.
Es ist die Geschichte
von Daniela und Dennis,
die sich trotz Diagnose
für eine Familie entschieden haben.
Amyotrophe Lateralsklerose -
kurz ALS.
Die Nervenkrankheit
lähmt schrittweise die Muskulatur.
Bei Dennis zuerst Hände,
dann Arme und Beine.
Über die Lähmung der Atemmuskulatur
führt die Krankheit
binnen weniger Jahre zum Tod.
Neun von zehn ALS-Betroffene
sterben innert drei bis fünf Jahren
nach der Diagnose.
Dennis hat Glück im Unglück.
Der 50-Jährige
hat einen langsamen Verlauf.
Er erhielt die ALS-Diagnose
vor acht Jahren.
Das geht immer
in einem Zug runter ...
Seit einem Jahr baut Dennis'
Kiefer- und Zungenmuskulatur ab.
Essen und Sprechen
werden immer schwieriger,
bis es gar nicht mehr geht.
Es gab mal
eine Episode in einem Restaurant.
Er bestellte ein Stück Fleisch.
Das war aber ziemlich zäh.
Dann kaute und kaute er drauf rum.
Das Stück war etwas zu gross.
Beim Schlucken blieb es stecken
und er versuchte es rauszuwürgen.
Das war alles schleimartig.
Irgendwann konnte er es mit
mehreren Würgeanläufen auskotzen.
Es war ihm unangenehm im Restaurant.
Wir waren mit Freunden da.
Seither schaue ich, dass ich
nicht so grosse Stücke schneide,
v.a. wenn das Fleisch
nicht so zart ist.
Ich sage ihm aber auch:
Wenn du es nicht runterschlucken
kannst und es nicht weich wird -
spuck es aus.
Der Profi im Reden mit vollem Munde.
Die Krankheit
hat das Leben von Daniela und Dennis
auf den Kopf gestellt.
Damit
gehen sie ganz unterschiedlich um.
Es ist immer wieder schön,
seine Einstellung zu hören.
Es klingt so einfach.
Aber ist man emotional gesteuert,
kann man nicht einfach fokussieren.
Es ist schwierig,
nur das Positive zu sehen.
Man sieht alles rundherum.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Was macht es mit dir,
ein Bild von dir in voller Kraft
zu sehen?
An seiner Leidenschaft
und dem Volleyballclub BTV Aarau
hält er fest.
Früher als Spieler
in der ersten Mannschaft,
heute als Coach.
In Dennis schlaffem Körper
sitzt ein unverändert wacher Geist.
Einen Finger kann er noch bewegen.
Für Dennis der Zugang in eine
barrierefreie und unabhängige Welt.
In naher Zukunft wird er diese
über eine Augensteuerung betreten.
Dennis, der Sportler und Kämpfer.
Das Credo:
Weiterleben wie vor der Krankheit.
Sein wichtigstes Ziel
hat er schon erreicht:
Tochter Melissa bis
ins Kindergartenalter zu begleiten.
Tschüss.
Mittlerweile ist Melissa fünfjährig.
(Italienisch)
Als ich im Sommer 2013
die böse Vorahnung hatte,
ging mir das
instinktiv durch den Kopf.
Ich dachte instinktiv:
"Ich möchte ein Kind mit ihm."
Auch damit ich
noch etwas von ihm habe.
Etwas Gemeinsames,
das wir uns teilen können.
Plus eine Erinnerung von ihm,
quasi eine Hälfte von ihm.
Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Ich frage mich manchmal,
ob es gegenüber Melissa korrekt sei,
sie auf die Welt zu setzen
und irgendwann
ohne Vater aufwachsen zu lassen.
Es wird mega schwierig für sie
und wir sind schuld daran.
Wir haben sie
in dem Wissen auf die Welt gesetzt,
dass ein Elternteil vielleicht mal
nicht mehr da sein wird.
Dennis' langsamer Krankheitsverlauf,
sowie Abklärungen zur Vererbbarkeit
bestärkten das Paar
in seinem Kinderwunsch.
Nein, er sollte nicht kippen.
Dennis' Möglichkeiten im Haushalt
und bei der Erziehung anzupacken
wurden immer kleiner.
Sorry.
Den anderen mache ich nicht allein.
Ich lasse ihn hier, ist das gut?
- Ja.
Okay, alle Fächer rausnehmen.
Ich will alles so machen,
wie er es möchte,
weil er es selber nicht kann.
Mir auch,
aber ich bin eine kleine Chaotin.
Wollen wir das jetzt ...
... so oder so?
Mal schauen, wie es aussieht.
Ich würde es so hinstellen.
So?
- Ja.
Die Füsse in der Ecke?
Heute unterstützen Assistenzpersonen
und Spitex die Familie.
Bevor Schneiders
externe Hilfe holten,
lastete das meiste
auf der heute 34-jährigen Daniela.
Non qui, Melissa.
Nach rechts oder nach links?
Alles schaffst du nicht.- Nein.
Okay.
* Scheppern *
Was passiert jetzt gerade, Daniela?
- Ich bin genervt, kaputt, müde.
Ziemlich angespannt. Merkt man das?
Ja.
Genau.
Gemeinsame Ausflüge bringen Licht
in den zunehmend schweren Alltag.
* Entspannte Musik *
Es macht mir Spass, wenn ich sehe,
wie die beiden spielen
und Spass haben.
Melissa liebt es,
mit ihm Fangen zu spielen.
Die Eltern klären Melissa so gut
es geht über die Krankheit auf.
Ich versuche, ihr zu erklären,
dass er vielleicht
mal nicht mehr sprechen kann.
Jeder Verlauf ist individuell.
Als Vorbereitung
nehmen wir sie an ALS-Treffen mit,
wo sie andere Betroffene sieht.
Da sieht sie, dass man auch
mit Computern kommunizieren kann.
Wir haben seine Stimme aufgenommen.
Wenn er mal nicht mehr da ist,
bleibt er so immer in ihrem Herzen
und ist immer bei uns.
* Melancholische Musik *
Die Ursache von ALS, mit Ausnahme
der seltenen erblichen Formen,
ist bisher unbekannt.
Pro Jahr trifft es
ein bis zwei von 100'000 Personen.
In der Schweiz
leben rund 600 Menschen mit ALS.
Ja, die dich duschen ...
Ja.
Ich habe ziemlich Mühe damit.
V.a. wenn die Rollen
parallel oder miteinander laufen.
Du pflegst deinen Mann,
bist aber doch seine Frau.
Das beisst sich irgendwie.
Ich ab und zu.
Aber ändern kann man es nicht.
Wie er sagt:
Es ist vergeudete Energie.
Das ist gegen
das Schwitzen im Leistenbereich.
Weil er sich nicht so bewegt, gibt
es Schweissansammlungen, die jucken.
Es gibt nichts Schöneres,
als mitten in der Nacht zu hören:
"Kannst du mich
zwischen den Beinen kratzen?"
Mitten in der Nacht. Das hasse ich.
Darum: präventiv eincremen.
Zähneputzen?
- Ja.
Danielas Überbelastung
und der unterschiedliche Umgang
mit dem Schicksal
belasten die Beziehung.
Ich helfe und unterstütze ihn gerne.
Aber ich habe Mühe damit,
wenn nichts zurückkommt.
Keine Aufmerksamkeit,
keine Anerkennung ...
Ja ... Nichts.
In unserer Startbeziehung
sagte er mir jeden Tag,
wie toll ich sei -
und das etwa vier Jahre lang.
Zwei?
Drei vielleicht.
Wir haben den Satz
sogar aufgenommen.
"Meine eigene Stimme."
Ich weiss, dass ich
nicht mehr so toll wie früher bin.
Ich mache viel,
aber ich komme an meine Grenzen.
Ja ...
Dann werde ich
ziemlich aggressiv und impulsiv.
Ich schreie viel.
Ich verstehe auch,
dass er mich in dem Moment
nicht gerne haben kann.
Umarmen kann er mich nicht.
Wenn ich schlecht drauf
oder traurig bin,
fragt er mich,
ob wir ins Bett gehen.
So kann ich mich
an ihn kuscheln und ihn umarmen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Mutter, Ehefrau, Pflegerin
und berufstätige Kriminaltechnikerin.
Daniela wird alles zu viel.
Sie begibt sich in Psychotherapie
und mietet eine Einzimmerwohnung.
Vier Wände,
wo sie Momente für sich hat.
(Aufnahme) Schenke jetzt deine
Aufmerksamkeit deinem grossen Zeh.
Spüre,
welche Empfindungen du wahrnimmst.
Ich bekam Hilfe.
Aber einfach zu spät.
Ich hätte mir die Assistentin
ein Jahr früher gewünscht.
Ich wollte schon da, dass sie kommt.
Ich merkte,
dass ich nicht mehr konnte.
Ich habe nur noch geweint.
Dennis gab mir einen Auftrag,
z.B. das Auge zu reiben,
und ich weinte einfach nur.
Bei der Arbeit auch. Ich sagte
meinem Chef, ich könne nicht mehr.
Ich habe immer wieder
meine Tiefphasen.
Da wird mir alles zu viel.
Ich fühle mich überfordert
und sehe keinen Sinn im Leben.
Ich denke, dass ich im aktuellen
Umfeld nie glücklich werde.
Dann wünsche ich mir
eine normale Familie.
Manchmal denke ich mir, dass ich
einfach die Pflegerolle einnehmen
und keine Gefühle mehr haben muss.
Fertig.
Aber das macht mich nicht glücklich.
Es geht nicht lange so.
* Melancholische Musik *
Auf Empfehlung der Psychotherapeutin
entscheidet sich Daniela
für einen Klinikaufenthalt.
Sechs Wochen,
in denen es nur um sie geht.
In die gleiche Zeit fällt
Dennis' vierwöchiger Reha-Aufenthalt.
Melissa ist derweil bei einer
befreundeten Familie untergebracht.
(Mann) Und dann dreimal reinhusten.
- Ja.
Nicht pusten, husten, ja?
Dann gucken wir,
wie weit Sie kommen.
So, und noch mal tief Luft holen -
und kräftig.
Ei, ei, ei, der war sehr gut.
Ja.
Ist das
wie ein Trainingslager für dich?
Wir sind bei ungefähr 320 l/Min.
Das ist weit im grünen Bereich.
ALS ist nach heutigem Stand
der Forschung unheilbar.
Mit Physiotherapie und Lungentraining
kann der Verlauf etwas hinausgezögert
und die Befindlichkeit
verbessert werden.
Und einen noch.
Jawohl.
Das war nicht geplant.
- Grüezi.
Einmal im Jahr wird die Kau-
und Schluckmuskulatur getestet.
Ich gehe jetzt an die Nasenöffnung.
Frau Schuller
gibt Ihnen einen Löffel Apfelbrei.
Er ist mit
grüner Lebensmittelfarbe gefärbt,
damit wir den Kontrast gut sehen.
Das ist nicht mit voller Kraft.
Es ist ein bisschen weniger kräftig,
als es sein sollte.
Ja, oder noch fester schliessen.
- Okay.
Man hört es schon an Ihrer Stimme.
Die ist ein bisschen nasal,
so nennen wir das.- Ja.
Eine genaue Prognose für Dennis'
weiteren Verlauf gibt es nicht.
Er selber fühlt sich
in der Halbzeit seit der Diagnose.
Und rechnet
mit weiteren acht Lebensjahren.
Während vier Wochen lebt Melissa bei
der Nachbarsfamilie mit drei Kindern.
Komm. Hänge bitte deine Sachen auf.
Genau. Schön versorgen.
(Mann) Melissa, war es gut?
Ich denke,
sie macht es ganz gut bei uns.
Am Anfang vermisste sie Mama
und Papa ganz fest. V.a. am Abend.
Sie hat mir dann erzählt,
dass Mami und Papi
ihr immer eine Geschichte erzählen.
Seither mache ich das auch.
Sie geht mit meinem Sohn Matteo
in den Kindergarten.
Sie sind gut befreundet.
Vielleicht ist es auch deswegen
viel einfacher für sie,
weil sie viel zusammen spielen.
Was kannst du noch
auf Slowenisch sagen?
* Sie spricht slowenisch. *
Bravo.
- Was heisst das?
"Du bist ein Marienkäfer."
Am Sonntag, am Wochenende,
gehen wir alle zu Papi und Mami.
Ist das gut?
Aber man darf nicht zu Mami gehen.
Nur auf den Spielplatz.
Ja, das ist doch super.
Dann darf Mami rauskommen.
(Italienisch)
Papi,
kommst du morgen zum Abendessen?
Ja.
- Yeah!
* Unverständlich *
(Vater)
Nach vier Wochen Reha sind Dennis
und Melissa wieder zu Hause.
Danielas Klinikaufenthalt
wird indes um vier Wochen verlängert.
Assistenzpersonen,
Spitex, Freunde und Dennis' Eltern
übernehmen Haushalt und Pflege.
* Spassige Musik *
Okay.
Grüezi.
Dennis, wie sorgst du dafür,
dass du Melissa nicht überforderst?
Schau, ich habe eines frei gelassen.
* Sie singt vor sich hin. *
Schau, dein Tier ist noch da drin.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Rheinfelden im Kanton Aargau.
Seit neun Wochen dreht sich hier
Danielas Welt nur um sie.
In Gesprächs-,
Mal- und Bewegungstherapien
findet sie zurück ins Gleichgewicht.
Ich konnte mich
mit mir selber auseinandersetzen.
Ich habe wieder zu mir gefunden.
Ich habe viele Entspannungstechniken
und den Umgang mit meinen Gefühlen
kennengelernt.
Ich brauchte sechs bis sieben
Wochen, bis ich realisierte,
dass es hier
eigentlich um mich geht.
Ich schaute
immer das ganze Paket an.
Aber es geht um mich,
meine Bedürfnisse und meine Grenzen.
Das hat nichts mit Egoismus zu tun,
sondern mit Selbstfürsorge,
Selbstliebe und Selbstakzeptanz.
Wenn das stimmt,
kann ich auch das andere meistern.
Dann bin ich gewappnet.
Mir wurde in der Zeit klar,
dass ich Dennis
sicher bis zum Tod begleiten werde.
In welcher Rolle
ist schwierig zu sagen.
Ich bin
emotional an die Person gebunden.
Vielleicht halte ich das
irgendwann nicht mehr aus.
Weil ich dem "Untergang"
nicht mehr zusehen will.
Weil mich das nur kaputtmacht.
Andererseits ist da Melissa.
Wie lange mag sie mitmachen?
Wie sieht es mit ihren Gefühlen aus?
Sobald sie mehr leidet, als dass
sie Freude an ihrem Papi hat ...
Wenn ihr Papi z.B.
nur noch bettlägerig ist
und nicht mehr kommunizieren kann.
Dann
liegt es in meiner Verantwortung,
Melissa da rauszunehmen
oder Abstand zu schaffen.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Daniela und Melissa
unterhalten sich auf Italienisch. *
Ein halbes Jahr liegt
hinter Danielas Klinikaufenthalt.
Dank
einer strukturierten Wochenplanung
und zusätzlicher Hilfe nimmt
sie sich regelmässige Auszeiten.
Okay.
- Okay. "Zylinderlinse".
"In welche Richtung rennt die Maus?
Dazu brauchst du zwei Motivkarten."
Ich bin noch etwas ängstlich,
aber zuversichtlich.
Es ist noch ein langer Weg.
Es kommen
immer wieder Stolpersteine.
Aber die Bahn steigt und
das Konstrukt ist nicht abgestürzt.
Das Grundgerüst hat gehalten.
Der Konstrukteur war gut.
"Fülle das Glas mit Wasser."
* Lachen *
Im neuen Jahr will die Mutter
schrittweise
zur Arbeit zurückkehren.
Dennis will auf einer Homepage
seine Geschichte erzählen
und Tipps für ein selbstbestimmtes
Leben mit ALS festhalten.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022